لقد أصبح إحساسًا فيروسيًا أثناء
الوباء
من مشاهير مثل كاثرين ماكفي
إلى الأمهات في محل البقالة
، كان الفستان الذي رأيته في كل مكان وكان
عليك فقط الحصول
عليه يسمى فستان الغفوة ، وقالت
مبتكر الظاهرة نيل دايموند إنها
لم
تتوقع ذلك أبدًا  لتصبح مشهورًا جدًا في
الليلة التي سبقت إطلاقنا لباس التطبيق ، أتذكر أنني كنت
أفكر في نفسي ،
حسنًا ، قد يكون هذا شيئًا رائعًا ، فهناك
فرصة كبيرة
لأن لا يرغب الناس في ارتداء فستان في
جميع أنحاء المنزل لا يجدون
فساتين مريحة قد يظن الناس
أنا مجنون وبعد ذلك ما حدث هو أننا
انتهينا من بيع فساتين القيلولة نوعًا ما
في كل مرة أطلقناها
من عام 2019 على الفستان الذي يبدو وكأنه
شيء مستوحى من بريدجيرتون على
Netflix ،
اسمي ladywhistledown ، إنها مجرد واحدة
من
العديد من العناصر المباعة  من منزل التل الماسي
الفراش إلى أردية الحمام حتى
مجموعة فساتين الزفاف التي تم إطلاقها حديثًا
ولكن فستان القيلولة أخذ حياة
خاصة به في
10 فبراير تقول الماس  لقد باعت
فساتين قيلولة بقيمة مليون دولار
في 12 دقيقة فقط ، لقد كنت تعرف إلى
حد بعيد أحد أكثر
الأيام إثارة في تاريخ الشركة ،
وأعتقد أننا قد أذهلنا
تمامًا الدعم المقدم من عملائنا.
نجاح الماس هو مجرد واحد من  قالت
العديد من الشركات التي أسستها نساء والتي
انطلقت خلال الوباء ،
وهي علامة تجارية لملابس النساء
تشتهر بملابس السباحة ،
إنها شهدت زيادة قدرها 700 في المبيعات
العام الماضي
مقارنة بالعام السابق ، وأنشأت كيلي
بالير مجموعة أوستن بيبي
بعد أن ألهمتها فكرة إنشاء
صديقة للبيئة  منتجات وجبات الطعام الودية للأطفال
والتي تقول إنها تُباع الآن في أكثر من
1000 موقع مستهدف ، ولكن هناك شيء واحد
تقوله Diamond أنها تعلمته أكثر من
أي وقت مضى
هو أنه لا يمكنك القيام بذلك بمفردنا ، فنحن فقط
أقوياء
مثل شركائنا وشريكنا من
Fedex  الأشخاص الذين يقومون
بتسليم طرودنا
إلى الأشخاص الرائعين الذين يعملون في
مستودعاتنا إلى
شركائنا في المصنع في جميع أنحاء العالم
،
وعندما بدأ الوباء ، أعتقد أنك
كانت الاستجابة الفورية هي تسجيل الوصول مع جميع شركائنا
والعمل معًا حقًا للوصول
إلى الجانب الآخر